braga obrigado pelo convite dele ex
braga para bem-feita clara tanta gente
aqui dentro ter pessoas ao lado ficar
com muito medo e nervos até muita gente
aqui de qualidade tal como eu sou eu a
fazer hoje o pet não vocês vou começar a
pura o que eu tinha escolhido que esse é
um tema não se está aí mas não quer que
era ser como never say never nunca dizer
nunca a gente tem que ter uma
mentalidade por isso então eu disse lhe
falaram que queriam sobre ser diferente
é ser autêntico
então é assim quando ele nas fazendas em
diferentes âmbitos diferentes de nós
temos um país diferente tudo é diferente
depois começamos a entrar no na vida e
chegamos a um sítio chamado escola ea
escola começa a dizer que a gente tem
que ser iguais a gente entramos todos
temos que fazer matemática iguais e
todos temos de saber isso
sérgio iguais quem quer ser um caminho
diferente às vezes é chamado o nome eo
carimbo rua eu não sabia de mais um
tributo
eu não gosto mas eu não gosto de ciência
eu gosto de não conta tanto com os
outros
sabes nem com os outros
obrigado a todos
e depois é que eu penso em inglês pois é
pra ser em português mas às vezes há um
bloco
então depois de a gente sair da escola e
começamos a perceber que afinal nós
somos todos iguais e é melhor ser
diferente fazendo chegar algum ponto
então fomos condicionados a ser iguais
iguais iguais
depois vemos o que afinal não é tão bom
é melhor a gente só ter quem éramos
fazemos o que queremos e começaram a
sair e é o que aconteceu a mim não quer
eu hoje vou dizer aqui uma coisa que só
duas pessoas nessa sala sabem só mais
uma pessoa que já fora dessas salas é
que são duas pessoas duas porque uma
houve uma dizer à outra e é que eu fui
para a escola
consegui sair da escola sem estudar
muito tive sorte é eu consegui ouvir
depois quero ver as provas sempre tive
sorte nisso mas sair da escola e
consegui terão um ipi na cidade quer sem
conhecer o alfabeto nunca ainda hoje não
conferido a até à última
não consigo e na escola é paa cup a vu é
a professora tinha que ir lá em cima e
olha pra lá a game e com aquela só da
mcm eu perdi a vontade esqueci a fazer
mão e eu consegui entrar já 51 ao saber
que o irmão e eu ia ter vergonha de
dizer isso mas é lá que deve sair depois
também agora quanto os que verão começa
a escrever as palavras e não acabou só
começa a escrever aventou a reunião eu
fazer um dois até então todos olhar eu
transmito deputado
eu acho que tem uma das leis mas lá na
escola tem que ser bom de fazer na minha
mala às vezes o albert se olha para o
mal a acabar as coisas eram os três
serão contra uma nova berlinda - o pior
de caiboaté o tempo 22h
imaginam a euforia de uma nota por que
mudar isto cantava que ouviu os outros
pra porque consegue ficar mais inspirado
e foi isso que eu também depois vi aqui
uma outra coisa chamada opera mini nas
lan é nossa amiga susana mostrou e eu
também com certeza esse método é o
ginásio nós mesmos não é tão fácil
qualquer comida vem com domingos em
qualquer sítio
depois começamos a ficar um clima mais
velho nós média começa a ficar mais
gordo mais feio tivemos uma casa maior
um carro melhor comida sushi já não dá
um quer impor o leite eo nós mesmos
começa a ficar gordo para caraças
mais ou menos como também na verdade um
crime foi de 40 e complicando através de
vida então o nosso mesmo quando a via
será o contrário felicidade primeiro e
depois vamos ver o que vai acontecer com
isso as suas notas que eu comecei a
fazer e como fazer isso acontecer vamos
ver como eles quanto tempo o google não
tem o direito a ter medo de criticar a
guerra como vamos fazer isso acontecer é
entre aceitar que não somos perfeitos e
notifica todos dizem eu não sou perfeito
pois a gente tenta sempre temos medo de
falhar a fazer um erro porque não ser
perfeito york o que a gente faz é o
crédito que acusa opção prefeito
eu não sou perfeita mas o teu amigo tem
que ser o teu pai têm que ser professora
tem que ser o nosso político nunca vai
sair tem que ser não vai ser exemplo tem
como aceitar isto só de começar a
acertar coisas dessas é que a gente vai
começar a ficar contente em nós porque
já não tenho expectativa que tudo é pai
de todos são perfeitos porque não são
não são roque
ele tem que aceitar essa respondi a um
laptop
faz-me tex deixe seus filhos fazerem as
tags ao erros porque é muito importante
é como eu aprender eu fiz muitos erros
meus pais deixavam método elisa mais mas
a verdade é que nunca diziam é pano
verde um senta e eu tentava e corria mal
mas eu aprendia tanto
aprendi muito com minha juventude vai
tentar aprender sempre aprender não era
sempre levar sempre a aprender o que é e
isso é muito muito importante e vou
dizer porque é importante
eu gosto de titica eu gosto de números
não sou bom a trabalhar os mais gosta
daqueles básica permitem são paulo
itaqui um número bem 508 em média todos
os dias
moro em 150 mil pessoas no mundo 150 mil
pessoas
ok é uma pena
vocês vão ter uma vida que não chegamos
a ser melhor que podemos ter sido nem
tena
a gente saiu de pessoas nem eu fui até
forró ea boa pessoa
ok e alguns dizem por ainda bem que
houve foi um mês ninguém pode fazer você
tentarem ser melhor discussão roche
ganhou voto potencial sem você e você só
podem fazer isso todos podem dizer toda
podem vir aqui falar e quem tentar
motivar mas não no fim quem vai fazer
vocês melhor são vocês que tinham
rendido quando o normal é você não é o
seu sócio não é o seu cliente não é
aquilo outro gás que não sabe o que está
a fazer e depois vai aqui com um negócio
meu lado estava isto não é ou é vocês
através para ser feliz temos que
concluir aceitar isso não ser perfeito
mas provar a responsabilidade nossa e
tal responsability eu já fiz antes eu
estava dizendo que eram os outros não
conhecia ninguém com quem podia
trabalhar mas eu não quero
depois também temos que começar a
perceber como não é tão mau porque isso
é outra coisa que gostamos
é pá está mesmo mal tudo mal da merda
porque não é para já viram o turismo
atende 70 doença tanto problema estamos
batalhando tem um amigo morreu tem outro
morreu a qualquer doente 200 anos atrás
200 anos atrás de você ser um grande
problema porque a média de vida era 31
[Música]
já não tinham já sob a vigência
quer eu já tava na primeira há algum
tempo atrás 31 era a média agora também
com 82
entendo ser melhor porque ouvi que a
espanha agora chegou a 87
temos que melhorar isto é não gosto nada
disso segundo a espanha então temos que
pensar muito bem que tenhamos melhores
50 anos atrás em portugal cada vez que
não tinham mil crianças morrerão 77 10
mil em de agora em dia saem mil morrem
três é melhor ainda não é só com o wii
dói me imagino que do iraque é o tempo
todos os números são melhores
estamos a melhorar mas é tão fácil
resolver o que é negativo é tão fácil
quando começa a ver coisas negativas vão
ver um carinho muito para trás e vão
perceber quem estava há 40 anos atrás em
portugal vai perceber o que era portugal
40 anos atrás eu lembro de ficar 30 anos
atrás
em portugal eu lembro em aquecer a água
eu vinha da áfrica e não sabia que havia
micróbios dentro d'água e temos que
aquecer e coisas é depois melhorou e deu
um salto enorme como é que a gente pode
dizer as coisas não confies então e com
a nanotecnologia de que ouvimos hoje com
mentalidade de pessoa vai ficando na
hora de acreditar se a gente quiser o
pior
essas críticas que está fica pior fogem
delas são os homens que querem mais
homens querem vocês vão morrer
o zumbido mora em campinas morrem e é
melhor fugir desses bancos porque não
vale a pena
late show tem a opção do chute não é tão
curta e 82 coisas que a vida não é tão
mau que vão dizer os nossos jovens agora
só tá no sangue e é essa
um segundo computador sempre houve um
problema sempre algum problema quando
vai o livro temos muitas letras relatam
livros é terrível lista que está mal já
nem falam só lêem livros saia televisão
olha o diabo
aqui tem umas antenas ensina o diabo não
olha para utilizar então até é bom ficar
vamos a um bis com essa válida conseguir
sobreviver os livros conseguindo
sobreviver à televisão eo computador
wells e de respeito não sei se alguém
conhece começou a usar cai diz tudo era
mais diabos estamos bem mal as pessoas
vão jogar aqui já não sabem falar não
sabem nada nunca foi muito mal agora em
dia só assumiria
estamos atrás do nosso em frança o outro
nome visitou o coritiba muito mal obras
da zmao rival já então olha por sua
desgraça volta a jogar e esportes
toquei padre temos agora é ponto com a
bíblia ou a barbie tem que ver em três
diferentes e não podemos estar todos a
jogar futebol
não há câmeras do g1 só que aí então não
precisam estar pensado com isso confiam
em mim o desafio do rio verde
depois de a renault abedi não é tão bem
como eu disse eu também escrevo em
inglês depois foi o português campeão da
nba zona de conforto
eu não gosto de falar em pessoas
eu falar uma língua que não é bem uma
língua nunca mas saiu o experimento
porque acho que pelo menos alguém
perceber uma coisa olha ainda bem aqui e
eu saio de zona de conforto deve dizer
alguma coisa e tentou sair da minha zona
de conforto muitas vezes tendo por meus
filhos saírem da zona de conforto muitas
vezes é fácil não porque eu não quero
que nada aconteceu mas quando a gente
fala uma coisa que me faz contente é meu
filho no mundo
a melhora porque eu já passei por isso e
sei o que aprendi aqui já pai que forças
13 anos num barco e boa sorte porque
havia alguém na tchuto olha a moçambique
os conheciam quando chegar lá e buscar
ao amigo da galera é basicamente a minha
idade tem alguém na áfrica do sul que os
conheciam que não conheceu a língua nem
nava e pesavam que durban de perto de
johanesburgo é e não é sempre que o
índice não tem nada a ver
e é isso que a gente com essa gente tem
sido a nossa zona de conforto como é que
eu faço eu todos os dias comece por sair
da minha zona de conforto coloca coloca
comércios em zona de conforto com o meu
netinho é aprender a trabalhar em vários
anos em áfrica é coisa que eu deteste
mais ia tentar lhe uma casa bem que está
a correr a água gastar agora temos aqui
uma palavra só para elas saberem até eu
detesto estar água e o que acontecia ao
desempenho dos que passa a água ea gente
espera aproveitar a quentinha e depois
entramos eu nunca vivi centro sempre com
ela fria
ponho e o dia se todos os dias eu digo
hoje vamos parar vai ser o dia que eu
espero eu ponho entrar
rápido clique e começa o meu dia
será minha zona de conforto do que se do
quinto e um estudo e continuo dia por
tentar sair da minha zona de conforto e
com cada vez que eu ouço alguém me
dizendo que não temos um problema eu
fiquei excitado olha vamos lá ver o que
é foi agora pode haver uma solução
também de time a gente já sabe tudo no
final bilac
não não me ajuda eu gosto ver onde vamos
fazer uma coisa diferente como é que
vamos pensar diferente e 777 tem sido a
zona de controlo do coisa orgânica é
grande pois depois outra coisa não tem
medo que vem aí a não tem medo de que a
errol bote ix tudo bem aí também mete
medo vou perder o meu emprego não vai
haver empregos ante 3 sejam mais um nome
possível e vão sempre ter emprego
os computadores osni robótico é anon não
ana não perdoa e um mais criativos e
seriam mais humana são mais criativos
são marketing são mais uma mostra opção
de crédito sejam pessoas e vão ter
emprego e vão encontrar coisas novas que
não ia vir e deixou o computador fazer
aquilo que ninguém quer fazer
quem não queria para atender confunde
porque o fio por ali que o fio para ali
a fazer de empregos que já não não
existem porque o povo sempre na hora de
a gente foi como eu disse jung percebe é
há ainda pessoas empregadas não tem medo
disso o dia a dia flex 150 mil pessoas
que moram em todas já não tem esse
problema não tem garantia vamos atacar
pra ver esse problema ea gente também
ganhamos um mundo tanto trabalho pra
gente tem que arranjar um único campo de
trabalho
relaxa dia a dia e pitimbu
agora aqui das coisas mais inglês tropa
a pé pois vamos aqui me an agent temos
uma responsabilidade de melhorar
melhorar o mundo e temos uma
profundidade quando a gente tiver filhos
da gente ser pais melhores que os nossos
países porque assim eu acredito que o
mundo fica melhor é da gente ser
exemplos fazendo tentar a melhor por
todos melhoram dessa maneira é simple a
gente quer sempre complicar as coisas
não é muito complicado
eu acho que às vezes hoje em ler um
livro e começa a ler e vai ser uma
pessoa com muito esperta como mas faz
tanta coisa complicada que seus pois só
faço sim mais um e coxim
ok eu faço isso a isso e como pensa
nisso é vocês fazerem o vosso business
prêmio porque 800 empresas vai mudar
precisa aprender o clone wars a nunca
fiz o meu é tão fácil vocês têm que
perceber por que vocês acreditam e não
acreditam em nada muito pena pois não
são um robot tibilisi tem que acreditar
em alguma coisa
quais são os nossos valores eu acredito
e tem valores que são isso sim ou não
precisam pensar não precisa não é um
empresário muito difícil porque por no
dia possa estar em condições de fazer
isso que vocês querem e os vossos
valores que fazem fazer fazer a divisão
para a esquerda ou para direita e se não
tiverem nava fazem várias vezes erradas
então é só pensar em qual o vosso
bicicleta é um tempo
é isso que eu acredito que o evento tem
que começar a ter mais respeito por nós
vamos fazer disse pra mim pra empresas e
para a vida e para os outros porque há
outras duas famílias também por outros
do mesmo
também tenho que começar a acreditar que
assim é porque eu falei duas línguas é
por isso que eu tive mais tempo
também temos que acreditar que a gente
somos abençoados às vezes somos os
cremes sorte porque estamos mesmo a
volta do mundo a gente que estamos aqui
temos aqui um docente sorte
o ibope pouca gente sabe mas o que temos
de melhor vida que 99% está fora
acreditam que não acredita que na massa'
os melhores a vai-vai aqui e lisboa
braga porto e v quando os aumentos vão
vir pra cá quando forneceram vim para cá
porque os portugueses vão viver uma
maneira só somos humanos somos
autênticos e amigos meus dizem sempre
isso porque eu gosto portugal as pessoas
falam comigo não com meus olhos tudo
isso é nossa maior exportação que não
podemos esquecer isso é tão só não
passar mais tempo
força força para melhorar o mundo
melhorar portugal melhor vocês próprios
começa aí
epá favor do escritor ap